I never thought my life would be oh my
god
cuz I've controlled and she kissed oh my
god I've got a golden twinkle in my
[Music]
today I am so excited and Nintendo has
given me this unique opportunity to play
the new Zelda game I got this tweet from
Shigeru Miyamoto yo poop I love your
bombast video almost as much as I love
cocaine and women here's the latest
build of the Zelda game I hope you like
it you guys know me I am the biggest
Legend of Zelda fan ever like if you
watch other Zelda fans on YouTube
welcome so I'm so excited to play the
new Legend of Zelda game I've been
waiting for this oh my god there we go
oh my gosh
I'd say it's the sells out game because
it's trademarked
really good choice of menu music ah but
father what if something happens to you
I'll take the Triforce of courage to
protect me
you don't hear from me in a month and
Linc
huh oh boy oh my god mink are usually
wearing lipstick to rock got a butt hole
that's links but Hall first move the
Triforce to pick a place on the map
what then press button 1 I'll fly there
in a flash you all should cancel Vella
can fly now this is the real name kind
of controller to move me left or right
great up and over makes me late
where's the button to kill yourself
luckily I brought my smart sword
it won't hurt anyone friendly smart
sword what it is an iPhone what the [ __ ]
I'm on you oh but I still have to sell
the stuff alright now we know how to
play Oh God
music I love it it's the best let's do
what's the difference between start game
and you okay new game please okay how
about we go to our ooh a hey we're in
Africa ha ha what happened they really
stepped up the graphics on the Nintendo
switch oh my god it's the Lion King
character whatever the resolution is
incredible the framerate is so smooth
this is unlike any gaming experience I
have ever experienced and you know I
always give you honest reviews like what
if I don't like something I'll be sure
to tell you guys I'll be the first one
stay also full disclosure this is a
sponsored video by Nintendo they are
paying me for this review a lot a lot of
money when I asked them to send me a
switch maybe not just not reply at all
and tell me to [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
happened there my left ear is really
enjoying since this is great the L oh
[ __ ]
oh my god oh my god it didn't die great
I always love honey tend to always
innovate comes up with you you know they
don't put graphics first it's not about
the graphics it's about the gameplay
it's always been about the gameplay it's
run away from these ok now we can go
here excellent
hey it's gret it's granny granny I
killed her
wow that was fun hello dearie I'm just a
minute off you go
I love her smile she's so happy about
the blanket whoa
I can shoot blankets now thanks to
granny she gave me the blanket sword I
should like it snap through my sword
I love Legend of Zelda it's my favorite
game ok we're done here
we are done here we have the blanket
stored now we could go to Tokyo power no
actually we're going to go to Mikado
shoot the blankets lock it
bring it dinosaur rat lock it shoot the
blanket [ __ ]
you're not going to get me this time
[ __ ] dinosaurs why am I not shooting
blanket Saturday excellent
having a lot of fun hey it's Christopher
Lloyd thanks for sharing Chris suffered
some is Zelda not enough really what is
with the [ __ ] character movement it's
like of crap you'll have to wipe out a
few more go Ria's to get back okay now
we got the rope we got the lantern let's
get out of here
[Music]
you just have to appreciate the vastness
of the universe and in this Legend of
Zelda game : six eyes and it fires me it
really does it really does environment
let's go to cook Co beat on the hell is
this guy doing what you're just going to
ignore me like that
come back here boss where's it going oh
[ __ ] take blankets [ __ ] okay this is bad
alright let's go in here honestly I
think this might be one of the best
cells out there everyone keeps talking
about the Ocarina of Time like it's a
classic it's time for going to get
better
III I don't want to say too soon because
you know I will only been playing for a
few minutes but I really do think this
[ __ ] I think this one has potential I
think we have a new champion is what I'm
saying let's [ __ ] smart
the demon from hell okay oh hey
I realize how sick Selda was he's doing
doing pretty well here so that looks
like she ate something really bad I
gotta say I really liked her art the art
direction they went with cool so now we
can go in here and his talk to this hey
how you doing John Mullen has eaten
everything I give anything fun up a girl
shake Pixar Pixar needs to hire the
animators this is the new generation of
animation look at their faces their
expressions hey instead of Swedish flag
finally hey Sakura Miyamoto you crazy
bastard you put that little reference in
there for me thank you thank you so much
it's very kind of you right I guess I
guess now we go to add a B paru the
[ __ ] desert when do I play is linked
I I don't I don't know I don't just link
it's busy [ __ ] there we go
all right [ __ ] eat oh great
I feel so good to play Legend of Zelda
game again it really reminds me of why I
love videogames and why how quietly
Nintendo always ceases to amaze me with
our innovation some would criticize them
and say that they're trying too hard to
have to innovate and I say yeah I say I
say they're haters disgusting haters
they don't understand sells out like I
do okay no one understands the selvedges
payment let's go in here that seems
great
holy [ __ ] at the crab great glad we did
that
can the crab be killed yes it can
excellent we kill the crab everyone I
repeat the crap no oh [ __ ] I can walk up
here Oh for [ __ ] sake ah please make
this jump for the gut gemacht dinosaur
okay make it jump
oh [ __ ] sake [ __ ] off they keep coming
jump it's impossible the jump is
impossible I can definitely see myself
thinking about six six thousand hours
into this game I really want to max that
all the character do all the side quest
and of course pay for the hard mode
later on the DLC I really look forward
to pay for something that shouldn't but
just be free tip again here we go yes
hell yeah
nice jump over the gold update here have
a drink
thanks yeah I jumped over that [ __ ]
[ __ ] thank Jamie now if my theory is
correct we need to blow up to the farm I
mean rock how do we do that
excellent now go right we have one more
chance it didn't do anything
it has mercy after you've scrubbed all
the floors in Hyrule then we can talk
about mercy so when you beat the game
you kind of wonder like what happened to
link
what happened Jesus Christ
you know this may be a little biased
review because I am such a huge ladyness
elephant this is it go out and buy the
Nintendo switch right now it's going to
change gaming forever it is incredible
stank it is breathtaking 300 now excuse
me I have to leave because I want to die
I want to die a horrible death
it's the only cure for what I've just
witnessed so I'll see you in never but
here's another video anyway and just
check that out if you'd like if you like
that thanks again for Nintendo to
letting me play the game really
appreciate it thank you so much love you
guys so much and a Brophy